the new european bauhaus is a project of
hope 2021 has just begun
vaccinations have started they will help
us to get a grip on the pandemic
our massive recovery plan next
generation eu will support our economies
and societies
to recover faster and better
and the european union climate targets
will help us to tackle the biggest
challenge of our times
climate change europe
is looking to the future with hope
and determination and the new european
bauhaus
fits perfectly into this outlook
it's about how we want to live together
after the pandemic
while respecting the planet and
protecting our environment
it's about making good life affordable
and bringing generations together
it's about empowering those who have the
solutions for the climate crisis
it's about matching sustainability with
style it's about all of us
today i want to invite all of you
to participate in the new european
bauhaus project
we want to make this an inclusive and
collective process
we want to listen to you to your ideas
to your challenges
to your worries and to your solutions
together we want to shape the concept
of the new european bauhaus we will do
it in conversations and workshops
in digital formats and when possible
also on the ground
in spring we will launch a new european
bauhaus prize this prize
will reward first ideas that guide the
way towards potential solutions
the new european bauhaus will be a
project shaped by
all of us in all member states
and beyond from professional architects
to
citizen initiatives from ceos
of big companies to the innovative
startups there are
so many great ideas out there
let's bring them together in the coming
months we want to explore together
what exactly the main focus of the new
european bauhaus should be
let's discuss how to help different
generations live together better
how to encourage the use of organic
building materials
how to put design at the service of
climate
solutions or how to transform a train
station or an
opera house into a sustainable building
how culture can contribute to solve the
climate crisis
we are looking forward to this
conversation
and by autumn we will then launch calls
for proposal
for the first five new european bauhaus
projects
in different eu countries
it's an exciting adventure that we are
starting today
we count on all of you to make this new
european bauhaus a success
thank you